sony playstation it was GD see that all
the rumors started floating around about
the PlayStation neo the 4.5 this updated
version of the playstation 4 since then
it seems like everyone and their mothers
had a leak coming out of somewhere and
about this console so before we get into
their sort of their games and their
virtual reality stuff and Justin first
of all PlayStation 4.5 pretty much dead
on to be shown at e3 it has to right
you've had so many leaks you've had so
much information come out III is the
perfect time to introduce a new console
like this and it feels like it's about
time in that console life cycle that we
you have a really high adoption for
playstation 4 they're the dominant
console by hands down what's a way that
you can get a little bit more
subscribers get more people playing it
have a slightly more powerful system and
something that's gonna play into VR like
you need something that will probably
support virtual reality in a better way
because I think when they were showing
the virtual reality systems it's needed
some kind of pass through other ones so
there's a everyone always talks about
that and I know maybe I'm miss informed
but from what i understand that box does
not do any actual processing like the
way we traditionally think about cpus
and gpus doing stuff from what I think
sony has said that box is there to
handle communication of data okay so not
the actual process like writing dinosaur
something round yeah so that would
include audio and video that needs to go
to the headset right it can't just be a
straight cable yeah in that regard so I
while I don't think that if there is a
follow-up PlayStation 4 that it might
help VR I don't think that it's going to
be like this is the one for VR it would
be like we would see with regular games
they would just see an incremental
improvement based on the rumors anyway
the thing I think is really interesting
with this is it's not weird to get it's
not different to get a new console in
the middle of a life cycle we've gotten
the xbox 360's back in the day yeah you
get smaller versions of consoles that
are usually incrementally more powerful
but this is ps1 Playstations and radio
64 is the only console I can think of
that in a Saturn in the garage just
write that did not get like all right
rentals yeah but this is one where
they're specifically or people are
really highlighting this is a more
powerful version it is the same console
littles play the same games but it's
also going to be a better console and
that's a really interesting tactic eight
of course it's not marketing that's not
what they're going for us what's
leaked out this is what we're we're
latching on to and so it'll be
interesting to see how they spin that as
well yeah totally do you think this is
like the new normal Peter we're like
instead of was having these sort of you
know incremental schools which obviously
change elements of the console based on
you know the parts that they're buying
for instance and whatnot and but do you
think the idea of this sort of
incremental like in within the same
generation console is you know something
we're used to on the pc side do you
think that's the way we're gonna see it
going from now on I mean possibly you
know we think of generations in terms of
like these we don't rightly so like you
know big chunks of time yeah if Sony was
to come out with the PlayStation 5 just
play devil's advocate we wouldn't didn't
say this a next-generation PlayStation
five right right right so if we look at
it that way like I think eventually we
will see a play station five but will it
be such a big leap from what we think
the neo is or what might be a follow-up
to the neo before the PlayStation five
no I think we're going to see these
smaller upgrades overtime persist but
there but we will still latch onto the
concept of this is a new era of
something but the days of these huge
gaps in technological performance
between hardware iterations i think is
done yeah oh has done a great job with
that with the the 3d s in particular but
before the 3ds the the game boy advance
and like how all of those bled into one
another you weren't able you were always
able to play her back had a lot of
catalog of games on the new system and
then when they came up with another
version it would cut out some of the
backwards compatibility had introduced
new functions for new games yeah get
punished for keys holding on to that
game boy micro I mean it's basically the
same we've seen in you know Apple phones
and you know I guess phones just in
general and on top of semana yeah so the
range to see the specs I mean that's
what ever wants to see right Xbox one's
new specs the scorpio and and 4.5
stepping away from that hardware into
Sony's other hardware thing the
PlayStation VR previously known as
project Morpheus and the second and the
trifecta of matrix themes hardware
iterations are kind of enjoy where are
we do you think with with PlayStation VR
all right because we're now living in a
you know post oculus you know post HTC
vive world where people have gotten
hands on it seems like there was a lot
of interest there for a while we're kind
of tapering off again where some people
have bought them and you know they're
not trying to get them in front of
stores to get people to buy them while
you
think about interest / PlayStation VR
Peter the advantage they have one is
cost to is the ubiquitous you know
number of play stations that are out
there but right the the real thing for
me are the sort of the properties that
will be used to create VR games whereas
a lot of games that we're seeing on five
and oculus are these new things that no
one really understands like yeah who are
these characters what is this world
PlayStation VR will be able to leverage
like Sony's you know great history of
titles and you know we not that I'm
counting this among the great history of
titles but you know you see like the
horror game that they're putting on that
sort of the on Rails yeah I know don't
talk about yeah yeah a little done thank
you yes and psychonauts is getting a
thing and that's not necessarily a sony
property or one that was ever exclusive
to their consoles but rush of blood rush
of blood sure yeah so but yeah I think
they'll be leveraging familiar
properties to get people interested into
it I don't think we're going to see many
grand experiences I just recently
finished playing insomniacs edge of
nowhere all right yeah which I believe
was made in tandem with oculus studios
so that won't be coming to PlayStation
VR but that was one of the first view
our experiences i played where it felt
like a full game like Chronos was there
as well yeah it's a really good game but
there was something about edge of Nora
that felt even more advanced in that
regard we riding the full experience so
I don't know if we're gonna get a lot of
that sort of thing out of Sony I think
that will take another year or so or
even be able to play experiences that we
already have in VR and uncharted 4 8
seems like it would might be a weird fit
for for VR but when I think about like
being able to pull back the camera and
see all around the world I as they put
so much time and attention and care into
these huge environments and expanses
like it would be so cool to have like a
little Nathan Drake running along on the
table I can look over and see this huge
statue in the forest is sort of like the
what they do with like the hitting and
go and Lara Croft go stuff but like for
yeah totally forgotten property I mean
at a certain stage even if there's just
a virtual raji option that isn't like
super I mean you need to have your sort
of tekken 7 supposed to have it great
can't wait I'm sure actually there would
be an audience for that but just not for
me and let's talk about I guess the
other aspect of that we talked about it
with our Microsoft discussion which you
can also check out if you're watching
this on gamespot our YouTube go check it
out
you can all we also sort of talked about
how you know what happens at Sony and
the reaction we have to that is so much
dependent of what we then or what we
have heard from Microsoft earlier that
morning and do you think if Microsoft
comment undo some sort of tie in with
oculus that then the PlayStation VR ends
up looking like sort of the lesser of
the two of those maybe two people who
aren't enthusiasts in terms of gaming
you know how they care about it because
I think oculus is they were really
notable because they were like okay
we're doing VR we're gonna do it first
we know what we're doing and they caught
everyone's attention Facebook bought us
for millions yeah and at this point I
think when it's devolved down to for
them because vibe is kind of stepped in
right and sort of taken over the
hardcore enthusiast market right oculus
is far more mainstream and if anything I
think microsoft needs to latch on to
that and that'll be good for them to
sort of define that but when it comes to
people you know like us who really care
about traditional gaming in that way and
how that can be brought into VR I think
PlayStation VR will be able to stand on
its own in that regard and not
necessarily be compared one-to-one with
oculus hmm ok a couple of games to jump
into first of all I guess we're gonna
probably see some nomads guy now
especially that it's been delayed a
little [ __ ] the man you know a show up
so no one's got the same focus though
like there was a big British oh and
that's something I really want them to
back off on a drive to see a lot of it I
want to see how the economy works like
all this sort of like what you do with
what you gather and what you discover
show me more of the that nuance that
kind of thing even I thought it'd be
cool when see if they have virtual
reality support that would be you know
if that might sell a bunch of
PlayStation of yours as well and moving
on a God of War for what if Sony Santa
Monica been working on for the past
couple years I guess they released god
of war ascension an incision battle
all-stars was that even write that was
that was somebody else but the I guess
you know it feels like a sort of a
mainline god of war I've been rumored
for awhile one without Kratos like a
starting sort of fresh thing and I think
the rumor is like setting it in Norse
mythology okay that a pretty cool would
begin interesting everyone liked gets
kick off that Europe your people have no
hot right now which are three everyone
was busy the same problem I have though
with this is that the issues we were
describing with gears are were for right
like God of War made such a big splash
and it continued to for a while but it
was helped somewhat by the advent of the
PlayStation
three like I sort of like jump started
the series again but since then it
hasn't really achieved the same sort of
like renown or attention totally so
maybe playstation 4 can help elevate it
a little bit in terms of graphics but
really like what sort of game play
things are they going to do they're
going to surprise us yeah it can't just
be the world that it's set in it can't
just be that it's a little bit prettier
than before yeah I think it really needs
to find a new way to define itself and
if it is indeed coming and it is how
they describe like I hope they can
leverage the world to do that yeah
that'd be great but you can rip the
eyebrows out of all sorts of new things
yeah totally different eyeball ripping
do you see I browser eyeballs eyeballs I
will eyebrows and put them in a box
character you never know how I feel
because huh layers of emotion I'll
written all over your face and another
rumor that's been floating around I mean
Sony have had the spider-man IP for a
while when it came to the movie stuff
that word that perhaps sucker punch are
working on a spider-man game like I
don't know if that's true or not or if
it's just that fanboy wish because
infamous is a fun game right but with
that spider-man skin it would be perfect
it's it's that so well but I don't know
how true that is and how much that is
just that's something that would be
really cool it seems like it would fits
like a dream yeah I mean second son was
a fun game I really enjoyed that I'd
like to see them you know maybe take a
deeper stab at it and yeah like I guess
what else we don't know what else has to
do is working out at the moment right
mmm look at always so what to see yeah
there it is infamous second son jumping
around downright cuts in that game for
some reason it's very weird really yeah
he's like a bunch of the like Russian
terrorist dudes that makes skins yeah
like real life yeah and this does
another great and resume floating around
a linkedin post for knack to ya mark
Cerny max Ernie's naki journey exceeding
sony journey yeah i mean mark two about
playstation launch games that i was
really hoping would get a reboot that I
just wanted to dive into again I
immediately think of knack they would be
tone deaf if they announced knack to I
feel like I hadn't heard of that game I
get in the years until i had heard about
that but but to be the mark cerny is a
powerful figure in selling it you know
like yeah architected PlayStation 4
weird guy to interview and which denotes
power I know I wish we had a recording
of Martin Gosselin's interview or mark
just stared at him and said nothing for
a minute yeah 30 seconds and but I yeah
I mean maybe you know he's the dude who
made a bunch of cool old playstation
games he could probably get away with
doing another one it wasn't a bad game
it was just like fine right lying game
it was exactly like Peter talked about
earlier where it's a game that doesn't
feel like it needs to be on this next
platform it's just Rises another very
old school game that's very pretty and
nice to look at but what does it do that
that elevates game that makes this in
any way a PlayStation 4 game yeah who
knows I bet it'll turn off I bet
bacterial turn off I just like putting
money on you know be great is if they
had Knack on screen and then to sort of
bring in a naughty dog they had crash
man could just like Donald young women
boost him up and be like wrong it's me I
mean yeah you know we're not getting at
the spot or scratch bandicoot has
reappeared recently I do you think maybe
they they go back to the the band couche
go back to the bandicoot water now I
actually don't I'd be very shocked if
naughty dog made a new crashed kind of a
one-note game like it's fun but like
what does a new crash bandicoot look
like it'll be the same problems Sonic's
had forever like they already did the
car racing like Sonic yeah they have to
haven't done a fighting game there you
go maybe a collector card game yeah
we'll see anything else in terms of Sony
rumors you guys want to talk about I
mean 4.5 seems to be the thing everyone
has their eyes on there has to be
something Sony's not I wouldn't say a
wild card but there's always there's
gonna be a surprise and I feel like you
were not gonna see it we're not gonna
have gameplay we're not gonna be able to
do it but we're going to get an
announcement for it we're gonna see some
really exciting trailers both for xbox
and and sony playstation think there's
gonna be something that i can't even
guess and that's what has me most
excited it's gonna be super predictable
and bring up Kojima of course yeah yeah
cuz there was an image that we you know
we got did a day that shows the face of
the character like within like the
mascot and yeah what is shakin I'm
coming uh I'll keep coming up I'll keep
coming and so there's disgusting Hideo
cuz there's two things about that one
was we had producer ken'ichi reminds me
on record as saying this is not an image
of or from the game were working on
right and which a lot of people took as
this is not going to be anything that is
related to a game right he sends
clarified with us like no that's not
what I meant what I meant was this is
not a screenshot right you can decide
whatever you think this is we're not
commenting on that so with that plus
with the fact that people were looking
at that image and realized if you
compare this angle to the hero shot of
Norman Reedus from the press materials
for silent Hills right it's like the
same I the same I fold straight of it
yeah so I think we're getting to a point
now where we're not going to see like it
maybe a trailer we might just see well
we might see a teaser yeah of what
they're working on cuz we know kojima's
making a game that'll be on PlayStation
4 that's kind of would not be mental
though because you're literally talking
about like less than six months passing
since he formed this studio but as he's
hair stuff something with the road lady
won't have something he's gonna show and
I mean he's a veteran he knows this
industry side of that sounds like like
that when you get your band together
your teenager and you make your website
before you written a song no it's like
well perhaps but you know I at the same
time I think that there's there's a good
chance that anything I mean look I mean
we we put up an image of the character
that people have already seen before
like ninety percent of that character
and it was I think the highest
trafficking story on the site really
yeah alright so anything that they do
will get people's attention and to not
capitalize on opportunities again and
missed opportunities yeah why wouldn't
they that'd be great love to see it
we'll have to wait and see not too much
longer only a couple days less than a
week before Sony take to the stage on
Monday ash probably four o'clock Stan
like that at a time at a time at a time
to be determined stop the term as we
know it on the internet somewhere go
google it let us know what you think
about Sonja in the comments below
you